hier soir invité de lci dans le cadre de
la course aux municipales à paris la
candidate et actuel maire de paris anne
hidalgo a été interrogé sur le moyen de
transport qu'elle avait utilisé pour se
rendre sur le plateau
si elle avait choisi de prendre le métro
en direct l'élu ps a visiblement été
hésitante quant à la ligne précise
qu'elle a empruntée je suis venu en
métropole en métro la ligne
puis
là je suis ou la ligne 3 je me souviens
plus d'hésitation que beaucoup ont pris
comme un aveu pour eux anne hidalgo et
déconnectés de la vie des parisiens et
n'est pas une habituée des couloirs du
métro une déconnexion de la part des
responsables politiques qui n'est pas
nouvelle on se souvient par exemple de
jean françois copé qui en 2012 avait
assuré que le prix d'un petit pain au
chocolat devait être entre 10 et 15
centimes
combien coûte un pain au chocolat tout
ça doit être aux alentours de 2 10 ou 15
centimes d'euros peut-être dollars la
même année c'est nathalie kosciusko
morizet qui pensent et quant à elle
qu'un ticket de métro coûté 4 euros en
2016 c'est nicolas sarkozy qui
s'interrogeait pendant une réunion sur
ce qu'était le site le bon coin il ya
quelques temps c'est le député les
républicains du haut-rhin jean-luc
reitzer qui avec un salaire mensuel de
5300 euros et la même chose en frais se
trouvait trop peu payé des déclarations
et des attitudes qui montre une certaine
forme de déconnexion avec la vie des
français dont ils ont pourtant la charge
de gérer
alors pour vous les responsables
politiques sont ils totalement
déconnecté vous montrez remonterait
l'extrait d'anne hidalgo et je vais vous
faire une petite analyse à regarder
l'unitaire donc allez-y anne hidalgo
comment êtes vous venu à d'hidalgo même
question comme moyen de locomotion
aujourd'hui je suis venu en métro mais
trouve la ligne
avi
je suis ou la ligne 3 je me souviens
plus mais je suggère régulière à la
régulière et je suis descendu
je suis venu
arrêtez arrêtez avec ça alors oui je
vais vous wright capituler et je crois
qu'on accomplit où elle voulait en venir
alors anne hidalgo elle a dit d'abord
qu'elle avait pris la ligne
une fois l'animal go voilà lé là elle
prend la ligne voilà in the go après
elle a pris la vie de neuf finalement
assez allant merde voilà donc la halle a
pris la ligne oder après l'or le diamant
lance pas la neuve c'est la 3e place et
puis l'a3 anne hidalgo doit arriver à
ici c'est tout près en fait voilà donc l
a dit ici j'ai tout près voilà alors
aujourd'hui
d'abord la question que tout le monde se
pose c'est anne hidalgo était-elle
vraiment dans le métro est-ce qu'elle a
pris le métro et ce matin à 9h02 une
photo venait mettre fin aux débats
puisqu'une photo ap rio prix a priori
volet se fait de la gueule de qui
non mais il voulait on n'a rien contre
eux ont fait mal politique aussi et je
suis aussi
non mais franchement genre y'a un mec
eric plus mais on sait pas d'où il est
sorti d'abord bravo eric il a mis une
photo publiée ce matin
voilà déjà on voit bien que c'est la
première fois le métro qu'elle prend le
métro elle a le sourire finalement déjà
franchement on voit en bois franchement
les mecs
elle a vraiment la tête de la meuf qui
prend le métro pour la première fois
qu'il fait bon écoute tu vois
franchement c'est sympa plein de gens
m'ont dit que c'était horrible bosses
trouve pas tu vois le prendre une fois
c'est ce pas alors voilà ok là elle a
pris donc a été dans le métro ligne 1 et
9 sortie porte de saint cloud pour aller
au débat helsinn franchement les mecs je
vous dis la vérité
si c'est pas de la démagogie ça c'est la
vérité
elle a pris le métro parce qu elle l a
voulu faire un coup voilà un coup
politique un coup médiatique
on sait très bien que d'habitude elle
prend la voiture il est d'avoir été vous
qui prenez le métro
moi je dis la vérité je prends très peu
le métro ce temps où le vélo ou la
voiture je le dis voilà mais franchement
faut arrêter outil qui a déjà j'aimerais
voilà soit la tête de ma mère il ya
beaucoup de gens qui nous regardent s'il
ya une personne qui a déjà croisé
hannibal
dans le métro à avant hier sur la tête
de ma mère cas face à tout tout de suite
ou qu'elle se taise à tout jamais non
mes frères gille ses limites au total
c'est du mépris de direction régulière
n'importe moi je passe ma vie dans le
métro tout le monde sait que la une ne
mourra jamais la 3c le principe tous les
paris alors où les usa et rila des
rumeurs c'est son chef de sécurité 1
voilà donc tout s'est arrangé
la une ne croise pas là 3 elle a changé
à franklin roosevelt ne sais même pas où
elle va
c'est n'importe quoi en plus alors a pu
prendre le rer traverser la seine alors
hébergé un peu rock rossellini pardon
dans mes filles il s'en fout de ça s'est
vite aussi la raison elle l'a pris et
bien sûr à la prière briac habitudes et
des défis fous territoire c'est
exactement comme lors de l'investiture
de hollande quand il a dit je suis un
président normal et qui s'est arrêté à
tous les feux s'étaient unis qu il sait
prendre les français pour des cons on le
sait très bien le cortège pour les
ministres et ses voitures de fonction
avec chauffeur et sirène pour les
députés et ceux qui sont à bercy
ces navettes fluviales donc les
embouteillages quelques rais depuis le
début c'est à dire avec les travaux de
voirie ce qui nous ramène des rats dans
paris elle en subit absolument pas les
cons ces normes et tous les politiques
doit pas faire un débat ce matin était
l'invité de france info a expliqué
qu'elle s'était emmêlé les pinceaux
parce qu'elle a l'habitude de prendre
beaucoup de lignes de métro différend
gazier la peau mais c'est ça mais grave
je sais que tu sais bien c'est plus
grave parce que elle a tout bon
la une la 3d 9 cd ligne qui vous apporte
saint cloud locale s'est embrouillé
c'est là que c'est plus graves séquelles
roma lalal raconte des bêtises regarder
en ce qu'elle avance sur les livres
regarder la mare
9 bon il se trouve que je prends
beaucoup de métro 1 et donc comme tous
les parisiens quand c'est pas ma ligne
habituelle je peux aussi faire des
mélanges avait pris la ligne 3 un tout
petit peu avant donc la une et la noce
et je suis descendu à la porte de saint
cloud voilà le tour est joué en métro en
hâte et j'ai très souvent le métro ce
matin je suis venu en voiture électrique
mais je prends très très souvent le
métro souvent la une souvent là où
dessous dans la douce soudan l'a3 bref
je prends un peu partout dans paris
non mais c'est comme la elle dit je suis
venu en voiture électrique scheer est
obligé de rajouter à 10 une voiture non
on n'est pas idiot elle est en campagne
est la vraie campagne elle a besoin des
verts pour être élu donc tout ça ce sont
des gages qu'elle donne au vert
électrique elia au travail sera pas élu
es les gens ils sont pas cons fois
arrivé je sers vous le dis oui son fric
à bien en voiture balai on se doute bien
qu'il ya des impératifs elle est pressé
il a bien sûr qu'ils ont été quelques
people pendant 84 ans souvent j'ai trop
nokia la prime est trop deux fois dans
l'année vous savez quoi je me coupe le
tessin testicules et je le mets à la
place du bateau alors comme d'habitude
et ça et voilà il est plus drôle ce sont
bien vous c'est vous les plus drôles je
vous le dis parce que sur twitter ça a
été magnifique
je vous ai fait un top 3 des plus
grandes rigolades sur la sortie d' anne
hidalgo
regardez il ya marco qui nous mais
regardez les chauffeurs d'hidalgo quant
à la ferme il est venu en métro voilà il
ya fibre idée david pujadas
êtes vous venu que vous êtes venu
comment anne hidalgo au métro comme
d'habitude on regarde très drôle et ont
tous pensé kendy une photo exclusive
d'année
c'est génial valoir ses géniales mais
ils se fichent de nous alors le métro ça
à chaque fois le grand truc des hommes
politiques pour montrer qu'ils sont
proches du peuple
il y est on a pris le métro et on a
truqué on a fait alors dire toi y en a
il ya nathalie kosciusko morizet c'était
en 2012 elle était ancien ministre des
transports
elle avait évalué le prix du ticket de
métro à 4 euros et quelques c'est
fabuleux
c'est la trop et quelques des transports
il coûtait 1 euros 70 ans regardez-vous
la porte parole du candidat du peuple
pouvez vous nous dire combien coûte un
ticket de métro 4 euros et quelques
années soixante dix je sais quoi de ces
journées 6,6 et son casse mais je
comprends pas bakiev osez-vous la
vocation pour vous il ya un autre beau
c'était jean françois copé le pain au
chocolat bras pop alors jean françois
copé si en 2016
il ya thomas sotto qui lui pose la
question combien coûte un pain au
chocolat et au bon voilà bruxellois un
peu il peut ne pas aimer les pros
chocolat peut être qu'il regarde combien
coûte un pain au chocolat
jean françois copé écoutez je ne vais te
donner aucune idée donc liés au tabac au
chocolat mais combien sa débâcle des
temps d écouter ça dépend des cas et je
pense que ça doit être aux alentours de
2 10 ou 15 centimes d'euros peut-être la
seule en euros 10 à nanoro 10 et 2 euros
vinci
le chocolat sentira du souk à 100 du lot
mes frères c'est des minimes frères ses
dépenses au delà des millicom non mais
alors il ya un autre bail
c'était luc chatel alors luc chatel
s'était non cinq minutes de l'éducation
nationale il avait séché en 2011 devant
problème de cm2 reinhardt sont pas
identiques coûtent 22 euros combien
coûte 15 de ces objets 10 objets
coûte 15 de ces objets dont 10 10 objets
au total 22 euros 10 objets identiques
coûtent 22 euros combien coûte 15 de ces
objets c'est la question posée dans le
cahier d'évaluation des élèves de série
a fait
16 50 noms et non dix objets identiques
22 euros combien coûte 15 de ces objets
ça fait 33 euros puisque des objets
combien coup mais je me serais toujours
sur une cuisine saine des gens qui nous
regardent et donc c'est à dire hualien
maman était devant bournat il est 6
heures du matin et tu te poses toi la
question des mines et toi tu de tes
hanches ramatou passé je sais que j'y
comprends rien de ce qu'il dit si la
sympathie je fais ça avec les fans gbc
vous tuer parce que là bas il est 6
heures du matin tu sais le mec qui s'est
levé il s'habille et la grave at il
s'est fait du ministre et tu vois il
arrive et là loterie oppose un problème
moi même maintenant je sais pas combien
je trouvais le shérif a compris trop de
moyens on a alors le plat pire du pire
celle qui m'a fait le plus de peine
c'est myriam alcoa france et myriam el
khomri hier c'était à l'époque la
ministre du travail
elle savait pas le nombre de
renouvellements du cdd alors aimer
regarder la la pauvre mais tout le monde
l'a tous ceux qui nous regardent ils
vont revoir nos têtes quand on était en
contrôle d'histoire géo et que la prof
elle te mets au tableau elle te
demandent une date confrères et ce à
tous les autres élèves qui tu regardes
et tu sais que tu es frère tu sais que
tu es comme on est tout seul que te
retourner le tableau tu vois pas de
sauver et regardez la tête qu'elle fait
d'ailleurs vous savez quel de la peau ça
a été la fin de carrière regardez quoi
un cdd peut être requalifié en cdi quand
justement le cadre du recours aux cdd
n'a pas aimé il peut être renouvelé
comme une fois le cdd il peut être
retrouver les plusieurs fois combien de
fois maximum je ne pourrai pas vous le
dire parce que vous ne savez pas
fois il peut être renouvelé deux fois
depuis savez-vous depuis quand depuis le
mois d'août dernier qui est une mesure
gouvernementale de votre gouvernement
sept aussi des mails comme henry oui bon
je vous le dis elle est jolie et très
sympathique
elle est très intelligente que non mais
c'est vrai mais là la pauvre quand
l'outil lui fait parce que jean jacques
bourdin tu mèneras sera vous ne le savez
pas quand il te fais ça et là tu te dis
mais dis moi j'y retourne en 4e je vais
là-bas 1
et vous savez pourquoi vous ne dites pas
parce que vous ne le savez pas la dame
elle conneries et là j'ai envie de le
revoir très bon mais là on va regarder
bien la tête et les blancs et la
poubelle bafouille et plusieurs fois je
sais qu'elle est morte envoie-t-elle
sexisme ses classes à ye ba bornes d'un
cdd peut être requalifié en cdi quand
justement le cadre du recours aux cdd
n'a pas aimé vraiment il peut être
renouvelé comme une fois le cdd il peut
être retrouver les plusieurs fois
combien de fois maximum je ne pourrai
pas vous le dire parce que vous ne savez
pas deux fois
il peut être renouvelé deux fois depuis
savez-vous de piquant depuis le mois
d'août dernier qui est une mesure
gouvernementale de votre gouvernement
cette fois ci rien mr comolli est bon
mais je vous le dis ça j'ai une question
à poser est où penser qu'anne hidalgo
prend le métro souvent voilà comme l a
dit oui non on va voir le sondage dans
un instant et puis l'année dernière il
ya une députée en marche
elise flagellait ce qui devait réagir
aux mouvements des gilet jaune
elle avait été très embarrassé par une
question de notre jean marc morandini
qui était pourtant simple le montant du
smic
elle a vécu un grand grand moment de
solitude
regardez s'élève le smic aujourd'hui
même un député
combien le jeu alors je vais vous dire
vous me faites vous faites une colle en
effet je ne connais pas mais vous vous
rendez compte
voilà là mais la meilleure ça resterait
mais rien de concret ce que vous trouvez
ça inadmissible c'est une faute qu'il
faut c'est une faute grave
oui bah oui vous pensez que tout ça
n'est plus un sujet ou alors ce n'est
même pas que les personnes qui se
présentent à la télévision mais personne
dans les cases ministre du travail je
dois savoir le cdd vis de l'économie et
les personnes à la télé voilà paré vous
mais voilà sur les prix des rez des
trucs moi je me suis fait avoir chez
ruquier sur la question sur le spi j'ai
dit une connerie j'ai des 1500 euros
avec ses 1200 bon voilà mes mémoires
s'emballent à leur travail politique
s'est pourtant excusé à combien de temps
chez ruquier
il ya trois ans parce que c'est parce
que c'en est c'est 1190 alors quel est
le prix d'une baguette de pain un os du
crâne et 90 g pas vous l'achetez mal et
très cher cette série un centime d'euro
à winamax 4 a dit qu'elle est un peu le
prix d'un timbre rouge 50 centimes non
un euro 16 vert 0,97 ou ce qu'elle est
le prix d'un litre de lait non c'est
cross 1 euros 20 75 centimes d'euro
qu'est ce que tu cherches le litre
d'essence
10 20 euros 63 ça le temps de chocolat à
90 1 euro disney tamachek labiche
dessous montendre et charmer les foules
une
là encore le ticket de métro à tout
facile ça c'est un euro sont de 10 84 ça
va un kit 1 kg de patates une patate
break 90 centimes et un euro 45 à
l'échelle moins cher et je pourrai me
donnez nous le montant de votre
prochaine augmentation 15%
c'est zéro je suis désolé de vous dire
ça mais là bon parce qu'il ya des
boulangeries qui sont avec des pains au
chocolat à 70 vous allez chez il ya des
boulangeries dans paris et dans son
secteur qui sont à 1 80 mais le blanc
chocolat il est aussi à 80 centimes en
banlieue il a loué la ville est riche
c'est à dire mélange les habiter chez
ricci pas les riches contre les pauvres
castaldi nous dit combien coûte une
aston martin
c'est dégueulasse qu'on m'écoute la
plaque
la petite martine ne renie sa 1euro 10
sur le banc chocolat castaldi tu habites
chez les riches david chesnais jo on va
voir alors les téléspectateurs sur anne
hidalgo
alors merci apparemment en régie sont
tous partis en métropole à la loi 94 %
des téléspectateurs et de pense qu'anne
hidalgo se fout de notre gueule et abat
93 maintenant car anne hidalgo vient
deux semaines voté avec anne hidalgo non
vous arrêter comme ça c'est des algues
au passage un autre encore plus
meilleurs alors tu voudrais cette date
qu'est ce qu'elle va faire et c'est une
blague c'est ce qu'elle a fait ça mais
elle a fait un truc cent fois pire
encore adidal que ça m'a sorti de mes
gonds j'étais la suite j'étais dans mes
gonds je me suis retrouvé là alors qu'il
passait rien c'était l'un des comptes
était venue en paix quand ça c'est rien
parce qu'elle avait bon sur les lignes
moi je veux des lignes de métro à laver
bon là je vais vous dire un truc je vais
vous lire dans une note ubs
après tout à quoi un coup de gueule
contre anne hidalgo c'est magnifique ce
qu'elle a fait quoi c'est vrai mais oui
je vous jure c'est toujours un point de
culture c'est du lourd dans la démagogie
mais tout est bien dans un instant
raymond nous dira pourquoi il est sorti
de ses gonds et vous voulez nous dire
maintenant pourquoi les quartiers riches
dont paris sont à l'ouest de paris sont
tous à l'ouest le 16ème 17ème nuit
blanche aux risques d'antan et les
usines ont un son de paris et qui crache
et la fumée et comme le vent vient de
l'ouest en région parisienne tous les
quartiers de l'est de paris en fumée
donc on voulait être d'en avoir un air
pur on est dans l'ouest achetait les
loyers de ses touches en banlieue c'est
plus cher
[Applaudissements]
il ya anne hidalgo nom et ou d'anne
hidalgo parce que alors je suis pas du
tout au courant de ce qu'il va dire
notre ami à la baisse tant du but mais
anne hidalgo a fait un truc de ouf
anne hidalgo qui est actuellement la
maire de paris elle va repasser ou par
elle ou rachida dati s'est elle est
encore freinée d'algues au sénat et
coûter combien de temps je suis pas
paris comme ça ce sera fait non non moi
je le disais tout à l'heure vous avez
été bien gentils parce que bon à la
dalle a parlé des lignes de métro moi je
pense qu'elle avait raison sauf qu'à la
marche et dix minutes pour aller chez
tf1 ce que porte de saint-cloud tf1 il
ya 10 minutes de marche avait dû se
faire poser resteriez ch
elle a fermé les voies sur berge c'est
chiant parce qu'il ya de la pollution et
j'ai demandé à vos équipes de retrouver
des images dont j'espère qu'ils ont et
efficace mois à l'adie instauré selon
moi at-il ont retrouvé à bravo aux
équipes
elle a dit un truc selon moi qui est
gros mais alors mais c'est en démago on
va le voir et vous donnez nous explique
un peut pas faire on peut pas faire mon
nom là je sais pas du hasard ajoute
qu'il serait gelé images mais bravo aux
équipes si l'on trouvait allez-y mais en
lisant bien votre programme sur le sujet
j'ai trouvé cette phrase cette
proposition on va trouver des solutions
pour les professionnels pour passer du
camion au vélo du camion au vélo donc
les déménageurs où les plombiers avec
leur boîte à outils ils vont devoir
apprendre le vélo 1 sur la voiture ou à
vélo
mais vous savez par exemple aujourd'hui
beaucoup de professionnels à paris
utilise par exemple des vélos cargo je
pense à des plombiers je pense à
beaucoup de personnes
et vous savez je crois qu'il faut
vraiment regarder le monde qui vient le
préparer ne pas regarder dans le
rétroviseur
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est une demande des ménages
d'ordinateur c'est la prochaine photo jt
mélange féraud mais von arx mais sans qu
on ait qui font les marchés les mecs moi
tous les jours sur mon camion et entre 5
et 7 tonnes de chargement mais je les
mets tous les sept tonnes soit en vélo
basso phase aller retour la cage alcine
d'arc à un déménagement vélo qui avait
dans l'air les noms mais à mon avis tu
sais quoi les plombiers vélo les
plombiers les chauffeurs livreurs les
ponts birel avec les noms et là cette
année c'est au tour de france à vélo
vélo cargo donc tous les gens si vous
voulez des livraisons mais non bord de
l'eau né au bord donnant vous livrera au
bord de lancer nan tu es gentil mais
année c'est vrai norman hidalgo à la
grenadine algo sont ma vie ces cas
ordinaires et anne hidalgo on n'a rien
contre toi ma chérie non c'est moi
ç'aurait voies sur berge fermé non mais
quelle voie sur berge frère tu te vois
toi maintenant tu vas les différents
vélo faire je vais l'aimer tout 70 car
tu vas voir les mollets mon frère ça va
être
et quand tu des ménages de nice à paris
sur l'autoroute avec le frigo de ça il a
raison c'est beaucoup mieux que le métro
où je suis d'accord ça c'est
extraordinaire c'est alors qu'elle se
démonte pas là ma femme elle argumente
il ya david pujadas et lui dit les
plombiers les trucs donneront beaucoup
tu es bon tu racontes mec t'as jamais
fait 58
une charge de 12 tonnes de moules non
mais sans déconner si kamber tout cas
les parisiens vous savez quand le
bonheur connaître bientôt frères tous
ceux qui mordent tube arrivant dans le
sud l'été parisien
[Applaudissements]
impossible de dire des conneries
pareilles sans déconner ça mais moi je
t'explique je leur passer tous les jours
bravo
franchement je vous devant la troupe
voix la sienne nous regarder une dague
auquel viennent devant raymond et moi et
le reste de l'équipe qu'elles viennent
juste nous expliquer cette dar k voilà
c'est tout elles viennent
elle vient à nous dit voilà qu'est ce
qu'elle a dans la tête la sphère du
manthey s'est pas posé locaux et parce
que pujadas lui repose trois fois elle
est bien sûr et c'est pour ça tout art
que vous parlez des tickets de bus et ce
en train de se prendre la tête sur des
histoires de ligne on s'en fout la ligne
ça c'est vrai à mon avis je suis moi je
te dis à mon avis il ya quelqu'un de sa
famille ou son mec qui travaille chez
bmx